bonjour bonjour
[Musique]
je suis venue libérer des femmes qui
étaient bloquées depuis 3 semaines et
leur bébé j'ai dû payer une facture de
130 dollars
nous sommes restés ici pour qu'il n'y a
pas derrière les docteurs nous a dit
jusqu'à ce que vous aurez d'argent c'est
pour cela vous allez donner moi-même
j'ai commencé à balayer seulement à
l'hôpital
le travail j'ai balayage je fais les
entretiens de l'hôpital puisque avoir
quelque chose pour payer à l'hôpital
[Musique]
l'objectif est clair je voudrais que
demain ça s'arrête que demain dans mon
pays que les femmes accouchent dans les
bonnes conditions qu'elle soit plus
retenue parce qu'elle ne peuvent pas
payer parce que je me suis rendu compte
que dans les autres pays même
limitrophes de la RDC notamment
Brazzaville il n'y avait pas ce cas
[Musique]